Oh Oh que toi quand tu vas
t'oreiller assez tu aimes étouffer ou
quelque chose hein
ça fuit ton truc sexy bruit ça
dit pourquoi réveille-toi oh non je serai juste
calme
hmm les mains en l'air
nous n'avons pas vraiment vendu mais nous avons besoin  pour
vendre notre maison pour payer la maison qu'on
vient d'acheter en banlieue il y a un
délai de 30 jours où si tout va
bien tu fermes qu'est ce qui se
passe là bas
salut on est tes voisins bienvenue a Kappa
nu c'est qu'un grec  restaurant oh c'est
notre sororité
je ne peux pas croire qu'une sororité déménage juste à
côté qu'est-ce qu'on va faire bébé ce n'est
pas que les mauvaises filles sont généralement calmes
ne prennent pas vraiment de drogues dures et elles sont
beaucoup plus intelligentes non j'ai tué une fille dont
nous avons besoin  quelqu'un qui peut s'identifier à des
jeunes stupides
un voisin arrêtons cette merde
la chanson thème aboie mon laisse le plexi
déguiser tout le monde tu ressembles à un
psychopathe c'est un clown les gens aiment les
clowns
oh arrête de faire ça personne n'essaie jamais de
démanteler notre sororité j'ai  une idée que
nous suivons  h l'astuce de l'airbag qui ne
marchera pas si ça marchait avec les gars pourquoi
ça marcherait pour les filles les gars sont idiots
les nouveaux acheteurs ne voudront pas
vivre à côté d'une sororité faisons un
parents tu ferais mieux d'empêcher les jeunes de
s'amuser c'est un  peu difficile d'appeler des
flics sans téléphone, donnez-nous ce retour
ouais oh ça s'appelle liège idiot
ces filles sont hors de contrôle elles
utilisent leur sexualité comme une arme je veux en
sortir